was ihr hier seht ist eine Variation von
Produkten von denen euch zumindest die
Hälfte bekannt vorkommen sollte es sind
nämlich drei Klassiker und dahinter bzw
dabei steht immer die Luxusversion wir
haben hier beispielsweise die
klassischen YUM YUM Nudeln kennt jeder
von euch lieben vielleicht auch viele
von euch dahinter eine Premium Version
Lasagne gibt's bei jedem Supermarkt eine
ich habe die früher immer gegessen die
Bolognese hilft einem durch die Tage wo
die Mama nicht kochen konnte dahinter
eine vagio Lasagne darauf bin ich sehr
gespannt Ricotta ist spinati Tortellini
Tortellini ultra geil einfach kochen
vielleicht ein bisschen Butter selber
dazu man hat eine fertige Mahlzeit 2 € 5
€. wie groß ist der Unterschied zwischen
dem Klassiker vom Supermarkt und der
teure Version das wollen wir heute
wieder herausfinden los geht's mit dem
Rahmen Nudeln hier haben wir jetzt
unsere beiden Rahmen Nudeln YUM YUM der
absolute Klassiker chicken flavour hier
drüben haben wir was ganz Besonderes das
muss sich bei Amazon bestellen das sind
Rahmen die mit einem Sternekoch
entwickelt wurden sechserpackung 50 Euro
bei Amazon das heißt eine kommt ungefähr
bei 8,30 Euro raus und das ganze muss
ich wirklich lohnen einziges Problem
alle Schriftzeichen darauf sind
asiatisch das heißt ich kann damit
relativ wenig anfangen ich werde gucken
dass ich zumindest die Zubereitung
vielleicht mit Übersetzer hinbekommen
werde Koch Methode geschätzte Menge an
heißem Wasser 450 ml die Hälfte des
Deckels wir machen das quasi zur Hälfte
einmal auf weniger als man denken würde
oder das hier sind auf jeden Fall Öl und
Soße das hier ist auch eine Soße das ist
das Suppenpulver und das hier ist das
gebratene Schweinefleisch das bereits
gebratene ist wahrscheinlich einfach
gefriergetrocknet ob das lecker wird am
Ende ich habe da so meine Zweifel
Suppenpulver und Nudeln jetzt gehen wir
440 ml Wasser oben drauf okay einfach
bis zu der für Linie hätte ich mir auch
denken können kümmern wir uns weiter um
YUM YUM den absoluten Plastiker
wahrscheinlich weltweit so mit das
bekannteste Fertigessen 320 mm kochen
das Wasser Schüssel 3 Minuten abgedeckt
stehen lassen und alles auf einmal rein
ist auf jeden Fall ein bisschen leichter
würde ich sagen mein 70 Cent ist
natürlich auch unschlagbar für so eine
schnelle Zwischenmahlzeit dabei auch
niemand sagt wird von der Packung YUM
YUM Nudeln also können wir keine
erzählen das ganze decken wir jetzt für
drei Minuten ab und dann können wir
side-by-side testen ich freue mich schon
schauen wir jetzt einmal rein was hier
bisher so passiert ist also die sind
wirklich warm geworden hier auf dem
Deckel ich hätte es nicht gedacht hier
muss man sagen ist wirklich eine Menge
an source dabei also das hier ist
richtig viel Soße die haben jetzt auch
erhitzt sie ist auch wirklich flüssiger
geworden dadurch dass sie richtig gut
aus das sieht das hier guck mal wie weit
ist
hier jetzt noch mal Zeit bei side 8 € 30
vs 70 Cent Klassiker vs Luxusprodukt ich
bin sehr gespannt wie sie schmecken
optisch klar geht der Punkt eindeutig an
die ipodo Rahmen die pudo ist äh der
japanische Restaurantkette habe ich
gerade noch mal nachgeschaut
dementsprechend sind die Erwartungen
groß für diese Rahmen man sieht ein
bisschen Grün drin man hat dieses
Fleisch man hat so Zwiebeln die
wahrscheinlich gefriergetrocknet waren
hier drüben haben wir eine relativ klare
Brühe so schöne Fettaugen oben drauf so
wie man das vielleicht von der
Hühnerbrühe auch kennt wenn man sich
selbst eine macht so also probieren wir
das ganze einfach mal ich meine ich wäre
ja eigentlich auch nur wieder meine
Geschmacksknospen auffrischen und dann
zu beurteilen auf die Luxusversion
wirklich so gut ist weil ich habe auch
häufig schon junge im Rahmen gegessen
es ist halt ein absoluter Klassiker
diese Brühe ja die Nudeln haben diesen
klassischen YUM YUM weit kannst du
einfach weghauen so die atmest du weg
hast du mal Lust drauf das gibt dir aber
auch nicht also das ist keine wirkliche
Mahlzeit davon wirst du nicht satt und
jetzt probiere ich direkt die Brühe von
der Luxusvariante allein dieses trübe
diese Miso Brühe das liebe ich bei
richtiger Rahmen wirklich sehr und das
probiere ich jetzt
sehr lecker probier mal die Nudeln weil
die waren ja auch von Anfang an dünner
mit
die verschwinden auch so richtig also
die haben jetzt auch nicht so einen
schönen Bytes und das ist im Restaurant
schon mal was anderes finde ich sonst
als die Brühe ne Brühe ist krass jetzt
probiere ich dieses ominöse diese
Fleischeinlage weil das gibt's definitiv
nicht bei deutschen Rahmen nein weniger
schlimmer als gedacht aber es trotzdem
nicht aber ich würde immer drauf
verzichten was sozusagen ist dein
Gewinner YUM YUM oder Luxus wenn du das
Side by Side ist das bringt halt nichts
YUM YUM bringt halt nichts und die sind
richtig lecker reingeschmacklich
garantiert die Pudel Rahmen wenn ich nur
noch eins essen könnte in meinem Leben
und das hier erhältlich wäre im
Supermärkten in deutschen Supermärkten
würde ich safe das nehmen weiter geht's
mit dem nächsten Vergleich Luxus vs
Klassiker los geht's hier haben wir sie
also die vagiolasagne gegen die Lasagne
Bolognese das ist ja das sind wirklich
gruselig aus ne so ein bisschen so
Hartkäse oben drauf gerieben ansonsten
wird das wahrscheinlich eine
Bechamelsoße sein oben sieht jetzt
nicht toll aus
okay ich sag mal so sieht anders aus
aber sieht auch nicht aus wie 13 14 Euro
auf mittlerer Schiene 40 bis 45 Minuten
erhitzen anschließend servieren ab
geht's 160 Grad 45 Minuten und während
wir geduldig warten dass die Lasagne
fertig wird machen wir uns noch schnell
ein paar Tortellini dafür Salzen wir
einfach ein bisschen Wasser vor mir
steht die Luxusversion mit einem
Kilopreis von 20 € und hier drüben haben
wir die Klassiker Version die Supermarkt
Eigenmarke mit 7,60 € pro Kilo also
schon mehr ist das Doppelte da sollte
sich was tun wenn man sich das aber mal
anguckt Leute könnte das eigentlich
schon fast aus der gleichen Fabrik
kommen sieht wirklich sehr ähnlich aus
dem extra geschaut die einen sind aus
Troisdorf die anderen aus Remscheid mit
anderen Worten sie sind nicht aus
derselben Fabrik keine Chance gehen raus
an einen italienischen Lieferservice hat
mir eigentlich noch teurere bestellt
sind nicht angekommen schade darum
erstmal den Klassiker hinein sind aber
an und für sich ja wirklich eigentlich
eine komplet Mahlzeit weil du hast
Nudeln du hast eine Füllung in dem Fall
ist das jetzt Ricotta espinati das ist
der Klassiker für mich im Hintergrund
mache ich nur ein bisschen Butter warm
Salbei Butter einfach weil wir so extra
sind mein ja das sind fertig Essen die
wir heute testen aber ich finde so eine
Salbeibutter zählt nicht als kochen oder
einfach Butter warm machen die darin
durchschwenken finde ich schon sehr gut
weil die trocken zu essen macht ja auch
keiner und direkt den Kommentaren
vorzugreifen Koch mal wieder mehr ich
koche immer in 50% aller Videos die
werden nur nicht einen angezeigt deshalb
guckt euch einfach mal auf dem Kanal und
falls ihr das Gefühl hat ich koche gar
nicht mehr dann nehmen wir mal unsere
Nudeln und geben die einfach mit in die
Pfanne die teure Variante ja die sind
schon ein bisschen anders würde ich
sagen sieht doch mehr aus obwohl beides
sehen die teuren auf jeden Fall
einladender aus oder Klassiker liebevoll
angerichtet Luxusversion was heißt
Salbei auf italienisch
20 Euro im Kino 7,60 Euro im Kilo
erstmal zum Auffrischen der Klassiker
ich habe diesmal wird für die
Luxusversion schwer die macht schon echt
alles ziemlich gut so der Ricotta innen
drin ist schön cremig klar Salbei
schmeckt auch raus aber schön identisch
schöner bist habe ich vielleicht auch zu
selten richtig gut gegessen und zu sagen
es ist eine Klassiker Version kleine in
Deutschland jeder Ecke krasse Tortellini
hier drüben jetzt einmal die teure
Version
verstehe was da abgeht auf jeden Fall ja
tatsächlich wenn du in einem Restaurant
Ravioli bestellt ne dann haben wir
häufig so ein bisschen ja das haben die
die teuren haben diesen bis hier sind so
total easy zu kauen aber die haben
diesen Biss der sie irgendwie teuer
wirken lässt also das erinnert mich
wirklich an die wenigen Male wo ich im
Restaurant so Ravioli bestellt habe oder
Tortellini bestellt habe also frische
Pasta mit Füllung was ich mir vorstellen
kann ist aber trotzdem dass die Nuance
nicht groß genug ist
wir haben diesen biss ich würde fast
sagen dass es unser erstes Unentschieden
und ich meine Unentschieden heißt beim
Preis Punkt natürlich dass dann der
Klassiker eher gekauft würde interessant
ist es aber allemal weil die
unterscheiden sich aber trotzdem ist
keiner der klare Gewinner anders könnte
das aussehen bei unserer Lasagne die
jetzt auch fertig ist und wir gucken uns
das einmal an
sieht auf jeden Fall unterschiedlich aus
so viel kann man glaube ich sagen
bestell dir noch ein bisschen unter den
Grill und dann gucken wir wie das Ganze
schmeckt der Moment auf den wir alle
gewartet haben 13 Euro Lasagne gegen
1,90 € mehr 22 Euro im Kilo 4,75 € im
Kilo ein riesiger Unterschied und ich
muss ehrlich sagen dafür dass das hier
400 Gramm sind sieht das so aus als wäre
es mindestens das Doppelte auch wenn es
nur 600 g sind wir fangen mit dem
Klassiker der mir ehrlicherweise ein
bisschen Angst macht weil das hier ist
komisch das sieht nicht lecker aus und
1,90 €
kann ich mir nicht erklären
viel Zucker drin und wenig Salz dran
schmeckt generell nach weniger einfach
ne schmeckt nach sehr wenig also es
schmeckt wirklich wie Babynahrung so ein
bisschen zu wenig von allem die
Konsistenzen sind nicht besonders gut
aber 1,90 €, wenn man keine Zeit und
nicht viel Geld zur Verfügung hat dann
kann man das mal machen so ist es nicht
wobei man für 1,90 wahrscheinlich besser
einfach selbst irgendwie so ein Gemüse
Reis trinken sich zusammen zaubert jetzt
wird spannend wirklich die Portion sieht
doppelt so groß aus ich mache hier mal
einen klassischen mittelschnitt ich
finde fast direkt auffällt ist diese
Fettablagerung ja dieses Öl hast du hier
gar nicht das stimmt die Frage ist auch
wann darf man eine Vagina Lasagne
vagulasagne nennen wenn 18 % VAG
Fleischanteil drin sind die habe ich
gelesen probieren mehr
schmeckt Bro das ist wirklich allein
dass beide sind Lasagne sein soll ist so
unglaubwürdig ist wirklich knusprig oben
drauf gewonnen und so beim ersten bis
nachdem ich das als Kontrast hatte muss
ich direkt wirklich an unsere 100
Stunden da sein die denken boah die
schmeckt richtig schön intensiv fettig
knusprig die macht wirklich fast alles
richtig was in Lasagne machen soll man
muss schon sein das ist eigentlich fast
eine doppelte Portion wenn du dir noch
so ein Salat dazu machst dann kannst du
zu zweit essen dann bist du bei 7 €
passionsgröße jetzt probier mal bitte
ein bisschen
[Musik]
das ist wirklich so
das ist krank ne also die schmeckt
wirklich so viel mehr und damit ist auch
egal wie teuer die ist gesagt dass dies
mehr wert ist vielleicht.de haben wir
die gekauft Empfehlung sehr sehr lecker
macht nur nicht die Grillfunktion an und
boah vorbei also wirklich hammer lecker
hätte ich nicht gedacht Freunde das war
mal wieder eine Folge Luxus was ist
Klassiker ist gestaltet sich super
schwierig Produkte zu finden mit dem man
das Fortführen könnte deshalb wenn ihr
welche habt wo ihr sagt okay damit müsst
ihr das machen bitte bitte in die
Kommentare schreiben hier ist ein für
dich vorgeschlagenes Video kannst du
einfach draufklicken das hat der
Algorithmus für dich ausgesucht darunter
kannst du meinen Kanal abonnieren falls
es noch nicht getan hast Kuss auf die
los bis zum nächsten Mal ciao